how close are we to making a real
lightsaber and I don't mean one that
just looks like a lightsaber I mean one
that can do this
[Music]
far away are we months decades centuries
let's find out first of all we need to
identify what a lightsaber is as well as
all the things it has to be able to do
to be considered a lightsaber so to see
exactly what constitutes a lightsaber
let's take a look at the Star Wars films
[Music]
okay first of all the lightsabers need
to be able to cut through metal and
people's arms what else probably the
characteristics of a lightsaber that
make it the most dramatic and exciting
to watch are one the glowing beam but
two the sounds that it makes as you
swing it back and forth those are some
of the most iconic aspects of a
lightsaber okay so they have to be in
the shape of a blade of some sort have
the iconic lightsaber color and make the
classic lightsaber sound effects we all
know and love anything else the
lightsabers are powered by a diadium
power cell the beam of a lightsaber is
contained by the force powers of the
user being channeled through the kyber
crystals so they have to be handheld or
portable and have a very strong power
source like a kyber crystal but most
importantly they have to be able to do
this
okay
[Music]
so in total there are six key functions
our lightsaber has to be able to do now
let's take a look at current lightsabers
and whether they're able to meet any of
these six key functions first of all we
have the plastic toy lightsabers which
can range from cheap five dollar
versions to some reaching well over a
thousand dollars that have some crazy
realistic lighting and sound effects
while a lot of these model lightsabers
can actually be used for dueling most of
them can't extend or retract like a real
lightsaber would but that isn't the case
for Disney's new hyper realistic
retractable lightsaber featured on the
galactic star Cruiser experience at Walt
Disney World to be able to witness this
lightsaber first hand you'll have to
Shell out a few thousand dollars though
this immersive yet expensive experience
will get you up close to the lightsaber
but you won't be able to use it yourself
and still this lightsaber can't duel or
cut through metal so let's take a look
at some more hardcore lightsabers ones
that can cut first off we have Alex
Birkin of Alex lab he's built a handheld
lightsaber that uses an electrolyzer and
burner to make a plasma torch that can
reach temperatures of 2800 degrees
Celsius or over 5000 degrees Fahrenheit
this lightsaber can cut through steel
and it looks pretty much like a
lightsaber from the films and its design
the drawbacks of this one are that its
blade looks more like Flames than an
actual lightsaber blade and it sometimes
explodes in the user's hand uh-oh Alex
isn't the only person trying to build a
lightsaber though James Hobson and
hacksmith industries have made five
different iterations of their lightsaber
design starting out with just heating a
long piece of metal until it became red
hot and able to cut through just about
anything now though they've been working
on a retractable plasma blade that looks
very similar to a real lightsaber the
power source and fuel can all fit on
your hip and it's powerful enough to cut
through metal they even found a way to
change the color of the blade by adding
in different chemicals although
hacksmith's most recent iteration of
their lightsaber is the closest we have
to the real thing right now there still
are a few drawbacks for starters it's
still a flame-based blade so the length
of the blade varies sometimes and it
can't really be swung like a true
lightsaber also while the flame sounds
pretty cool it doesn't make the classic
lightsaber sound effects so if we're
still not quite there and making a
real-life lightsaber how could it be
done well what if we started with
something in the name of the lightsaber
light researchers at Harvard and MIT
have found a way to make light act like
a molecule they were actually able to
make three or four light photons act
like an object that cannot be passed
straight through so if we were able to
make millions of these light photons do
this in a narrow area we could actually
create a unified beam of light that
would work much like a lightsaber but
for now they've only been able to turn
light into molecules in a super cooled
vacuum and doing so with millions of
photons would be very difficult so this
option is likely not accessible for a
very long time probably the closest
thing we'd ever get to a real-life
lightsaber would be one with a super hot
plasma blade held together by strong
electromagnetic field powered by a
microscopic antimatter power source
wait what a lightsaber is a beam of
contained Plasma in the Star Wars
universe that is contained using the
force in actual physics Labs we contain
plasmas using large electromagnetic
fields and nobody has been able to
contain a plasma and a small beam like a
lightsaber but you know maybe someday
we'd be able to so a lightsaber blade
would be made of super hot plasma that
can expand and retract within a given
area and this area would be surrounded
by a strong electromagnetic field that
holds the plasma together this type of
magnetic field would even allow for
actual lightsaber duels or for
deflecting Blaster bolts since the
magnetic fields of each lightsaber or
bolt would just bounce right off one
another making an electromagnetic field
such as this would require a lot of
energy though and I mean a lot one
solution to this could be anti-matter
antimatter is something that sounds like
science fiction but it's fact and if you
mix antimatter and matter together you
get a crazy amount of energy even a
single gram of antimatter could produce
the same amount of energy as an atomic
bomb so just a few micrograms of
antimatter would work to replace the
kyber crystal power source there might
actually be just a few micrograms of
antimatter inside kyber crystals which
Powers the lightsabers we see in the
Star Wars films there are two main
drawbacks to this kind of lightsaber
though first of all plasma is very hard
to contain in an electromagnetic field
because it's made up of charged
particles
charged particles moving around make
their own magnetic field so you have the
magnetic field of the containment but
then you have the magnetic field the
plasma makes and the two of them
interact and it's very hard to keep a
stable field with that very very
complicated process right now if we
tried to create a plasma lightsaber it
would look nothing like what we'd
imagine and it would in fact be so large
that we wouldn't be unable to hold it so
for now our lightsaber would be the size
of a football stadium rather than a
handheld weapon the second issue is that
making the anti-matter power source
would be very expensive and we've only
been able to create one nanogram of
antimatter in the Large Hadron Collider
estimates put the cost of producing one
gram of antimatter at over 25 billion
dollars so getting the lightsaber of
your dreams probably isn't in the budget
so how close are we really to making a
lightsaber for fully functioning
lightsabers exactly the way that we see
them in the Star Wars films at least 100
years away and it would require a lot of
time and money invested into making
lightsabers a reality for lightsabers
that look pretty close to the real thing
and don't require a big bulky pack on
your hip probably within the next few
years and for lightsabers that can cut
through metal and make you feel like a
Jedi well we're already there oh come on
now this is like the coolest thing ever
so check out the video on your screen
for some more of my content don't forget
to like And subscribe and thanks for
watching Rocket Riley
[Music]